I actually did feel very guilty I had a
lot of inner conflict for many years
when I first began the sport I felt that
was maybe going against my religion and
it really really used to tear me apart
at the same time I loved the sport and I
couldn't understand how that could be
wrong
I realized that I was living a double
life you know one that was a nice
traditional girl at home and the other
where I succumbed to the gym and that
was another side of me
I remember the first time I walked into
the gym I was 18 years of age it was
quite a male-dominated environment but
none of that fazed me all I wanted to do
was participate in the sport
Mort i originally was designed as a
warfare art by the ties they used to use
it to defend their country it's known as
the art of eight limbs it's full speed
full pace full power and it's one of the
hardest sport in the world so it can be
quite intimidating I actually began my
sport training with Bill he has actually
become like like a father figure to me
he's took me under his wing at the same
time he puts on his coach hat he means
business I can't come up with excuses I
can't learn about them in pain or I'm
having a bad day when you're in training
mode you're in training the fact that I
come from an additional Muslim
background it's quite unusual to pursue
a sport such as mortai I was afraid that
my family might tell me sport or them I
remember coming home one day and my
father looked at me he said to me why do
we look like a boxer at that point I was
so frightened that the sport would be
taken away from me I run up to my room I
had one trophy I hid that because I
thought that's the one key that gave it
away down might be doing box living I
decided to tell them and I bought my
father down to the gym to reassure him
that all I was doing was exercising some
discipline in my life rather than being
out on the street getting involved with
things that I shouldn't be just knowing
that they know what I'm doing in my
spare time that's enough for me to
continue and make them proud I don't
want to walk away sitting in the
changing room crying my eyes out
thinking I could have done better
oh actually I had it in me to win that
fight but I gave up
except me you gets to forget about how
coaches forget about her supporters it's
all about what I can do in these ten
minutes of my life
you don't really have time for nerves
all you're thinking about is your neck
strike your strategy is it working is it
not am i hurting my opponent am i
winning the fight or what do I need to
change so you is very tactical obviously
if you get caught with the nasty shot
you're trying to face that out very
quickly and get back onto your game plan
to win a fight is one of the most
amazing feeling in the world
it just reassures you that all that hard
work all that sacrifice everything that
everyone around you the team around you
the nutritionist your training partners
all those nights trainings firing going
home with bruises all that is worthwhile
talent along is not enough it's all
about sacrifice is all about being
dedicated and it's never the end until
you give up
you